Tap, ¿sí o no? No.
¿El futuro Centro del Vasco linaricenter engross sí o no?
¿No? ¿Qué modelo lingüístico elige?
A, ¿b o d?
D estaría a favor de 1 parque eólico
en su municipio de residencia, ¿eh?
Depende de dónde y en qué circunstancias.
Desde luego, si fuera 1 lugar em
protegido o 1 lugar, ¿eh? ¿1 lugar ecológicamente
importante? Pues no.
Qué prioriza a soberanía,
¿b cuidados o c economía?
¿Creo que son perfectamente
compatibles y es lo que tenemos que conseguir
móviles en el Cole
hay que prohibirlos eh?
¿Hay que regular su utilización tanto como prohibirlos?
Me parece que que no funciona.
¿Considera que Donostia
necesita 1 Nuevo pabellón multiusos?
Pues lo siento, pero no,
no lo sé. Quitaría la deducción por compra de vivienda
para fomentar
el alquiler, ¿eh?
No obligatoriamente
Cris eh, se pueden estudiar otras vías,
pero sí es 1 posible vía sí,
¿igualdad
considera que hay que establecer cuotas de paridad
en las ejecutivas de los partidos?
Sí, mientras sea necesario.
Y por último, ¿tiene seguro privado o de salud? ¿No?